in my parents marriage like my dad is
the quiet you know how do you think that
works out for society though generally
to have women leading the households of
men
do you think that's a good thing or a
bad thing in some cases it is because i
can't sit here and say that my mom's
been a bad leader she's been a very very
good leader and the thing even though my
experience was that and it it does touch
on what you've said
i still went out and chose someone you
guys would classify as masculine because
the reason why i said is because you
know we're talking about the black
community about so black community have
like
60 to 70 to up to 74 single mothers
right and when they have like boys
a lot of the boys like there's a there's
a single parent to prison pipeline that
just can't be denied do you know what i
mean and so
a lot of the time both the women
so both the boys go to jail and a lot of
the girls
end up quite promiscuous
like they do you know what i mean and so
that father in the house is really
needed it's necessary
um so i have a question for you you said
um one of your fears um in being
submissive is that the guy will leave
you and then go talk [ __ ] about your
race or about like black girls is that
what you said
why why are women afraid when they leave
most of the time between 70 to 80 and 90
if they're college educated
wait okay so women women women and this
is something i hear a lot it's not just
you but i always hear women like afraid
of being left so in your case it's being
left for a white girl but i've also
heard women being afraid of getting
married and being left for a younger
model or you know someone else but it's
not women who are it's not men who are
leaving it's women
so women leave seventy to eighty percent
of the time if you're college educated
it goes up to ninety percent
so
why as women do we have this fear when
we're the ones that are breaking up our
own homes
got him daddy
that was a tumbleweed moment
let me just let me process it yeah
basically yeah women are the ones
leaving relationships um so for you to
be fearful
of a man leaving you you're more likely
to leave him
statistically yeah so to have that fear
is that level of control that you were
like talking about like he's like you
want total control of the whole
situation like you want to control
whether who's going to leave he's going
to leave i'm going i want i want to be
the one to leave and if he does leave he
can't leave before a white girl
yeah like what what
like what if what if um like black men
said that so they said i won't get into
a relationship with black women because
i'm afraid they're gonna leave me for a
while
you know this guy's a waste man
[Music]
i think i was just like generalizing
yeah why black women might feel that way
that's what i'm struggling to answer
because i don't necessarily feel that
way okay so okay but you've heard it yes
right literally generalizing so i could
be wrong but
piggybacking off the back of that sorrow
it also you often hear a woman will say
i'm scared to submit to my man to say to
be a housewife just in case
he's the one that leaves and then i'm
left with nothing financially but
when
the majority of women are hypergamous so
they date up or across
socially economically
generally speaking it's usually the man
that would end up being financially
worse off so i don't see where
fair enough if you're like from saudi
arabia where there's the divorce laws
aren't 50 50 and you are if you become a
housewife you're at the man's win but in
the western world where pretty much
every western country is 50 50. it's
usually the man that financially falls
out so why are men
not apprehensive of that but women are
can i can i address something right
and there's no white men here though it
will be interesting if there's a white
man here um the